so I went three bricks here okay three
bricks the three bricks represent ideas
concepts that build on one another okay
we're gonna look at scientific notation
which is this sprig here the one on the
top but in order to really get
scientific notation so I understand it
and be good at actually using it you
need to we need to review revise a
little bit to other ideas which you're
pretty good at but I want us to jog our
memory so the two ideas are index
notation the index notation that's when
you've got like something to the power
of something we'll have a look at in a
second row table index notation and the
other idea is significant figures okay
so significant figures index notation
let's just really quickly reveal and
then we'll build time to view notation
on top of both of them okay so your next
notation let's just draw up a quick
table okay two columns doesn't need to
be really why this is I just want us to
remember what this index notation me and
particularly what's it ever seen
positive and negative
okay so this is what the tables are
going to look like to call us we'll call
the left-hand column index for index and
we call the right-hand column values so
we're gonna write some numbers in the
next form and then think about how big
are these things okay so in X hey go now
rule a few rows here for me and I'll
leave it blank and come back to them in
ascending probably three rows that a
blank would be nice and it is for three
whew
okay let's write our first number in it
next four write them all with the same
base I'm gonna write 10 to the power of
one okay to the power of one now that
the index the power what does it mean
what does the one mean
it means 10 right
and I'm multiplied by itself yeah just
just once just once that's what the one
means okay so ten times itself well just
just once really that's just ten okay
now if I wanted to multiply by self
again ten times ten right how would I
write that I'd write it as 10 to the
power off to take the Kate multiply it
but so few once twice okay said to be
ten times ten its value would be 100
right it's ten times ten yeah it's okay
it's only in the time I get it all right
one more down opponent that'll be our
last row ten the power to the next one
would be 10 and half three right 10
cubed so what's that 10 by 10 by 10
we're multiplying right it'll be this is
10 times 10 if I multiply it by 10 again
I'm gonna add a 0 a 3 just be careful
okay yeah 10 times 10 times 10
okay so there's a couple things to
notice you number one how many zeros are
there each time how many zeros on it
well he unders 1 0 which corresponds to
the one right here
you've got to 0 which corresponds to the
two that's kind of nice and the easy way
to remember he there's three zeros 1 2 3
which corresponds to the fact is 10 to
the power of 3 okay that's good that's
the first thing the second thing is we
went down the table right and we kept
betting big on backwards we go up the
table we climb up from here to here I
divide by 10 can you see that right from
a thousand to a hundred I divide by 10
is that okay yeah yeah all right if I go
from a hundred to ten I'm doing the same
thing right divided by ten so if I go up
one more what do you expect to be in
that road if I'm dividing is 10 and I'm
dividing by 10
10/10 is one now that's the right hand
side following this pattern what would
you expect to see here in index form it
goes three two one
zebra 10 to the power 0 we'd okay
multiplying 10 by itself zero times but
if you follow the pattern you can see
what's going on okay let's follow the
pattern again going up again right
what's 1 divided by 10 we can write that
in decimal can't wait 1 / 10 would be
hmm you get your calculator it'll tell
you right 1 / 10 would be 1/10 right
what's 1/10 as a decimal it's zero point
one isn't it zero point one that's what
happened when I divided by 10 following
the left hand side I went three two one
zero
what would be next it'd be negative one
one minute the numbers are going
decreasing as you go up the table do you
guys reckon you could finish off the top
row for me what will be the left-hand
side 10 ^ maybe too good right I'm going
to divide by 10 one last time divided by
10 0 point 1 divided by 10 at 0.01 it's
even small long okay right now again
there's right a really helpful pad for
us how many zeros were there here it was
three matched up with this many zeros
are there for this there's one which
matches this Howdy's ear is done which
matches to this how many zeros this one
before the decimal place matches to that
and here there are two which matches to
them okay so you can see how many
patterns there are in this table right
now the reason why I chosen 10 is not
like 2 or 3 or 4 is because scientific
notation it uses these these tents and
it's actually going to be a really
useful table for us to refer to in the
future